[Musique]
oui ok j'en suis c'est vrai que tout est
allé très vite
mais c'est bien dans de former une
grande famille
allez viens je vais te présenter les
garçons ils ont hâte de rencontrer
tu es prête pour l'école tu pourras te
faire de nouveaux amis
je sais pourquoi chante l'oiseau en cage
l'oiseau rare c'est hyper daignera c'est
bon ça suffit ça nous arrive à tout
il nous a déjà tout fait pleurer et
inquiète tu devrais venir avec nous
après les cours
[Musique]
c'est quoi tout ça sème et une cérémonie
en son honneur
pourquoi vous voudriez mouret parce que
tu es là 4e tarifs pour ton premier
cycle c'est un peu de la folie douce à
la base pour avoir des pouvoirs c'est de
croire qu'on en a c'est pour ça que nous
a semblé ont toujours été importantes
[Musique]
si on est capable de faire ça qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire d'autre faut qu'on
jette un sort à timmy mais on va pas lui
faire de mal pas vrai
elle a raison la règle numéro 1
sorcellerie si une sorcière devient en
danger pour elle-même des autres ses
pouvoirs seront cédés
je commence à me faire du souci
désolé je traînais avec mes copines on
est allé trop loin
tout ça c'était qu'un jeu pour toi
chérie non
je me sens différente
faites gaffe avec tous les barrages qui
lie à dans la nature les barges c'est
nous monsieur